(zooming)
- Prove them wrong.
- Prove you wrong.
- Prove people wrong.
- Hello, Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn how
to prove people wrong.
And as always, if you hear
something that really resonates
with you, please leave it
down in the Comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
and if you're leaving a comment
within the first few hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes that we have.
Good luck.
(upbeat music)
- [Interviewer] Did you
ever have, let's call it,
a normal job, Conor?
A nine to five?
- Mm-hm.
Yeah, 'cause the Irish thing
is to get into a trade straightaway.
I was no different,
Soon as the day I finished school,
I was always getting pestered,
'What're you doing with your life?
Are you doin' this, doin' that?'
And they didn't know what it was.
They didn't know what MMA was,
they didn't know what none of this,
they didn't know I could
make a career out of it.
As far as they were concerned,
me ma and da I'm talking about,
as far as they were concerned,
I was just getting into a cage
and fightin' with some other guy.
They didn't know nothin' about it.
No one did really!
But I knew, you know what I mean?
I knew!
And then I ended up getting a trade,
just to keep them quiet.
'Cause I used to have a lot
of fights with me da a lot-
- [Interviewer] What trade did you get?
- I ended up gettin' a trade as a plumber.
Literally up in the back guys up an hour
up in the Wicklow Mountains.
And that site is one of the
biggest sites in Europe,
Kilternan was right at that skiin' place.
Huge, and now it's just abandoned,
now it's just deserted.
So I used to go up there, six o'clock,
five o'clock in the
morning I was on my M50.
I used to have to walk to the end for,
about half an hour from me house,
wait for some limerick guy
that I didn't even know.
He'd drive on the F4 and
I'd have to flag him down.
Nightmare, yeah.
Two hours down on the M50, two hours back.
Usually 14 hour days and
I was the first year,
so I had to go and do everything.
I had to the shop, I had to
go and get this and get that.
So I always had trouble with that
and I was like this isn't for me.
This is not for me.
- [Interviewer] How long did you last?
- I lasted 18 months doin' it.
But it was tough, you know?
Just wasn't the life for me.
And then John said, 'cause
I was training with John
as well at the time.
And then John got on twitch and said
I have a show, I'm running a
show, I'd you to fight in it.
And then that was it,
I just packed it in, didn't show up.
Me da used to come and
punch the head out me,
like try and drag me out of bed
and I just wouldn't go.
You know, I had upper
hour for a good few years
when I'm miserable.
And that was it, I just packed it in, quit
and then focused on trainin'.
And that's, I knew what
was going to happen.
I knew I was going to get here.
They didn't, it was a
lot of stressful years.
You know what I mean?
A lot of tough times.
But I proved them wrong,
I proved myself right.
- Don't ever let somebody tell
you you can't do something.
Not even me.
Alright?
- Alright.
- You got a dream, you got to protect it.
People can't do something themselves,
they want to tell you you can't do it.
You want something, go and get it.
Period.
- [Interviewer] You're
not against bullying?
- I'm not.
- [Interviewer] What do you mean?
- I'm not against bullying because
I feel like the world is bullies.
Like, there's so many people
who are going to tell you
that what you're idea is stupid.
Or you don't belong here
or you don't deserve certain things.
- But wouldn't it be a better place-
- [Donald Glover] If
people didn't do that?
- But you're saying you're not against it
'cause it's unrealistic to be against it?
- I'm saying we probably
wouldn't have Kanye West,
Bill Gates or anyone
without someone being like
you're not worth it.
Like we wouldn't have them.
And like we wouldn't have people
who were like no, this is worth it.
Because if everybody's ideas was worth it
and if they felt that way,
everybody felt like that,
we just have, it'd be like nothing.
Everything would be the same.
You need somebody to keep being like,
no, I'm right.
You need a Joan of Arc, who's like no,
I'm right, I'm right,
I'm right, I'm right.
Even if it's crazy, even if it's crazy.
But then eventually people are
like maybe they're not crazy.
- [Interviewer] Are you that way?
- I mean, yeah, I like to believe that.
I mean, people tell me-
- Because you seem like
such a modest guy when
you're on this show.
(laughing)
- [Donald Glover] I'm a salty dude though.
- Are you?
- Oh yeah, I remember
everybody who says stuff.
I got beefs with people,
like I remember stuff.
I remember totally and
most of the things I do,
it's just like, no I'm right.
And I believe in myself more.
- [Interviewer] You're vengeful?
- Not vengeful, I'm salty.
(laughing)
I'm like-
- What's the difference?
- The difference would be like.
Vengeful is like I'm going to
come and destroy you, I think.
Like, it's like I'm going to wait around-
- I'm going to, I'm taking
your number down and-
- And I'm coming for you.
- I'm coming for you.
- I'm salty, which means I
think salty is a different thing
because I'm like I'm just
going to prove you wrong.
I'd much rather you sit there
and be like, huh I was wrong.
Because then I think that's growing,
like there's lots of times
where I've done stuff
and been like I was wrong about
that and I didn't even know.
And then it makes you
look at things differently
on experiences in your life.
Like, I want to make people
think you were wrong.
- Ignore people telling
you your idea is bad.
They may be right but the only way to know
is to actually build it out.
And I think the thing that
works about Silicon Valley
that's different than Mexico City
or almost anywhere else in the world,
is the default response if someone says
hey I'm going to start a
start-up, here's my idea.
The default response is to be excited
and think like oh why might that work.
And in most of the rest of the world,
the default response when
you tell someone your idea
is to say oh that's not going to work.
And this is really toxic for start-ups.
'Cause you have to believe in yourself.
And the good ideas, because
they sound like bad ideas,
are so fragile and so killable
that you have to be really careful
to insulate yourself against this.
- When I found some place in my country
and a lady answered the telephone,
I then asked, to whom am I speaking?
She said, you're speaking to me!
(crowd laughing)
I said, well lady, I
know I'm speaking to you.
But what's your name?
She said, who are you to ask for my name?
What's your name?
(crowd laughing)
I say, well lady, as soon
as you tell me your name
I'll tell you mine.
But as we argued as to who should tell
(crowd laughing)
his or her name,
she became very cross and she said,
you seem to be a backward person
(crowd laughing)
have you passed your matric?
Now matric in our country is a
university entry examination.
And I said, well lady,
you must be very careful.
Because if the qualification
to speak to you
is the possession of a matric certificate,
I might work hard and pass my matric
and be in the same class as you are.
That was treason.
She said, you will never be in my class
and banged the telephone.
(crowd laughing)
How I wish she were here today.
(crowd laughing and cheering)
She would now discover
that I have achieved more
than passed my matric.
- And you know when they say
oh I would like you to do this for me or,
and I produce a lot of
first time filmmakers
but I don't produce all
that approach me.
And I say look if I say no and you give up
I'm sorry to tell you but
it's the wrong job for you
'cause you live with rejection for decades
sometimes as a director.
And you end up making the
movie you want to make
so if I say no that doesn't mean I'm right
or I'm wrong, you just say f him,
I'll show him later, you know.
I'm going to make it and
that fat bastard is going to
have to say I was so wrong
and hit himself in the head
because he didn't do it.
And I think that's the thing to do,
is show us, don't tell us you know.
Do the things.
And if you do them wrong but
you do I mean your own terms,
that's how I define success.
Failing in your own terms.
- Do you think that
people underestimate you?
Underestimate your how much
you work on this stuff,
underestimate your intelligence?
And my question is is that
something you push back on
or something you leverage?
- Definitely something
that doesn't bother me.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- When someone underestimates me,
I love to get to know them and have them
have one conversation with me
to just understand that it's,
I mean I think the
easiest question to ask is
what does she do?
What is your talent, you know?
And I jokingly said, actually
to my husband the other day,
I said, you know what?
My next answer should be, sarcastically,
how lucky am I if I don't
sing and I don't dance
but I'm still doing what I'm doing,
how easy is my job?
I don't have to do any of that.
I don't have to be on stage
like you working so hard
but we're still driving the same car,
we're still living the same life.
(crowd laughing)
So lucky me, if it was that easy.
But you know, I think it's
just the easiest thing to ask.
For anyone to really assume
that it's not a full-time job
to have to sit and create things
and come up with every single blog post
and I do, you know, three a day
and having to you know, working on apps.
To me, it would be the
same thing as people saying
like anything blogging.
Like, what do you do?
You're sitting at home in your apartment
and you're just on the computer.
Like that is such-
- I think people do
say things that about us.
- hard work, you know?
And I respect it so much, you know?
And they say that about
the modeling world.
Well, they just sit there looking pretty.
It is a full-time job for models
like my sister even, Kendall.
It's, I don't mind getting underestimated
but I feel for people
that I understand how
it could bother them if they
were put in the same situation.
Even filming a reality
show, it's a full-time job.
I think that, I know reality shows
don't get the respect that
I believe they deserve
and that's why I love
being on one for so long
and I will always fight to
be on as long as possible
because I love to show and prove
but my personality is just
if you underestimate me
I would love to have a
conversation with you.
I would love to, I just
like to prove people wrong.
- But I was dumping the
pasta one night into the sink
and all of a sudden Ramon Simone walks in
and he says you know Barbara
we have something serious to discuss.
I'm going to marry your secretary.
My Tina?
She went from Tina the
wonderful secretary,
I won't even put a label on her.
I just couldn't believe
my ears or my eyes.
I'm like what, how's that possible?
He said take your time moving out.
I took about a minute,
grabbed a toothbrush,
and walked out the door
and moved in with my girlfriend Kathy
who was living on East
79th Street in a studio
and she let me stay there 'til
I got my feet back under me.
I should say that for the
first time in my life,
I don't know what hit me.
I guess that hit me.
But I can't believe I managed it so badly.
I felt like I was a nobody.
I went from a somebody
with a successful business
to a nobody because I was
turned down for a younger woman.
Tina was five years younger than me.
I had to admit, she was prettier.
She had real blonde hair.
I was already highlighting.
(crowd laughing)
I hated her for that.
She was calm and pretty.
I hated her.
(crowd laughing)
But I went to work every day.
I wanted to fire Tina but Ray reminded me
he was the controlling partner.
I couldn't do that.
Tina moved into my desk in Ray's office
where I used to sit and I sat
out with the sales people.
And every day I went in
smiling like a puppet
but in my heart I was runnin' around
a broken heart and loss of confidence.
I just thought to myself my god,
I was nothing before Ray found me.
He picked me up, found me.
He was my mentor, he gave me confidence,
he gave me the money
to start the business.
Everything good that had changed my life,
all led to one place
which was Ramon Simone.
And I thought he's right, I'll
never succeed without him.
But I can't even remember
what clicked in my head,
maybe desperation, but
one day I just decided
I'm not going to do this anymore.
And I walked in and I
said to Ramone Simone,
you know what, I'm ending this business
and here's how we're going to do it.
We're going to chop up the 14
salespeople like a football draw.
You can pick the first
person, I'll pick the second.
We'll do it fair.
If you want to move out, you can move out.
If you want me to move out, no problem.
You want to keep the
phone number, no problem.
Or I'll get a new phone number.
Whatever.
You go first.
He picked Norma Hirsch,
our star salesperson.
I picked Ester Kaplan, our
not-so-star salesperson
but I had a plan for her.
And we went right down the line
and I would say within maybe six minutes,
we ended a partnership.
Boom!
Like that.
We had $37,000 in cash.
He wrote me a check for half of $37,000
and as luck would have it,
it was a real estate recession
we're just about to dive into
and why was it great?
Because commercial space
wasn't leasing well.
He was on the eighth floor,
where my old office was.
I rented the identical
space on the eleventh floor
above him, there was a little ego in that
I'm sorry to say.
How needy was I?
(crowd laughing)
And by Monday, this was on a Thursday,
by Monday, I moved my salespeople in
'cause in those times,
you could rent black
desks, rent phones, bang!
We were in operation and my
seven salespeople moved in
and that was the birth
of the Corcoran Group.
Right before I left Ramon
Simone's office that day,
or should I say Ray and
Tina's office that day.
And by the way, you know
what his real name was?
It wasn't even Ramon Simone.
I found out from his mother Vicky
his real name was Ray Simon.
And he wasn't from the Basque
country like he always told me
he was from 145th Street
in Harlem, go figure.
(crowd laughing)
Alrighty.
Well anyway, so right
before I left the office,
that's when Ray gave me
the gift of a lifetime
when he said to me those words
that reflected in my head
for the rest of my life.
It still gets me goin'.
You'll never succeed without me.
I'm telling you, I don't
believe in negative motivation.
I'm a positive person like my mother.
But he really knew my number.
If he had said I know
you're going to be amazing,
I'm sure I wouldn't
have stayed in business
in the tough times.
But it was that scolding
tattoo in my heart:
you'll never succeed without me.
That every time I was near-death,
growing my business
through the ups and downs
of the real estate recession.
Being overextended, being
over leverage, owing money.
Blah blah blah.
That same phrase got me goin' again.
He gave me an insurance policy
for success by insulting me.
Thank god he did.
I have thanked him a million times.
What happened to Ramon Simone?
He married Tina, they
have three kids together.
They are so much more happily married
than myself and my husband, Bill.
They were meant to be together.
(crowd laughing)
They were destined, okay?
But still, thank god
he gave me that insult
to insure my success
for the rest of my life.
- Do not listen to the naysayers.
If you are going to have a breakthrough,
you've got to be able to
silence the negative voices.
That's the next step and
that's the next secret.
Many of us have too many
people speaking into our ears.
I just called these people abortionists.
So you've got to be careful.
Your dreams, your visions, your desires.
Especially those that have been god-given.
I want you to pursue them.
I want you to believe that
all things are possible.
It is possible for you
to go back to school.
It is possible for you to
heal your relationship.
It is possible for you
to go at life alone.
It is possible.
- Seems to be that managers
from other countries come
and they are quickly
addicted to the place.
- [Pep Guardiola] Yeah.
- Have you spoke to
anybody on that behalf.
- Yeah, they told me
it's so hard, so tough.
And all the people say
Pep is not going to adapt
and coach in that way,
so that is why I'm here.
To try to do it so the people have
some of them confident it's going well,
but some of them in Germany as well
the people say the way you
play is not possible here
in the Premier League so.
And I said myself why not?
Why we don't travel there
to try it and that's why.
So it's a big challenge, not just for me
but I am always in my teams I
was able to emboss the players
and it went to help us here as well.
When that's happened,
everything will be easy.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed the video.
I'd love to know what did you think?
What was the single biggest
takeaway that you took
from this video that you're going to apply
to your life or to your business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below.
If you're within the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win one
of two daily prizes as well.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Eduardo.
Eduardo, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and taking that picture
and posting it to Facebook.
I really appreciate the support, man.
And I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(swooshing)